so if aliens do alien species were to
make contact forgive me for staying and
aliens for a bit longer do you think
they're more likely to be friendly to
befriend us or to destroy us
well I think for the most part our
they'll pretty much ignore us if you
were deer in the forest who do you fear
the most do fear the hunter with his
gigantic 16 gauge shotgun or do you fear
the guy with a briefcase and glasses
well the guy with a briefcase could be a
developer about to basically flatten the
entire forest destroying your livelihood
so instinctively you may be afraid of
the hunter but actually the problem with
deers in the forest is that they should
fear developers enough because
developers look at deer as simply
getting in the way I mean were the
world's by hto Wells the aliens did not
hate us if you read the book the aliens
did not have evil intentions toward him
Homo sapiens no we were in the way so I
think we have to realize that alien
civilizations made viewers quite
differently than in science fiction
novels however I personally believe and
I cannot prove any of this I personally
believe that they're probably going to
be peaceful because there's nothing that
they want from our world I mean what are
they gonna kick us what are they gonna
take us for gold no gold is a useless
metal for the most part it's silver I
mean is gold golden color but that only
affects Homo sapiens squirrels don't
care about gold and so gold is a rather
useless element rare earths may be
platinum based elements rare earths for
the electronics yeah maybe but other
than that we have nothing to offer them
I mean think about it for a moment
people love Shakespeare and they love
the arts and poetry but outside of the
earth they mean nothing absolutely
nothing I mean when I write down an
equation is strings
I would hope that on the other side of
the galaxy there's an alien writing down
that very same equation in different
notation but that alien on the other
side of the galaxy
Shakespeare poetry Hemingway it would be
nothing to him or her or it
you